اجمعين
رياض الصالحين
الحفظ النبوي
ابير
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏anyنائم
and
‏is
when they concluded a battle they would
gather all of the warot and place it in
one spot and a fire would descend and
take it away fire would descend and
you know burn the the war booties the
spoils of war make
‏propet صلى الله عليه
‏conuded his ble
and upon doing so he had his troops
gather all of the spoils of war in one
place and they awaited for the fire to
come and devour
spoils of war and that as well was a
miracle of their prophets
and it
الله سبحانه وتعالى
جهاد الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
يقول
فجمع الغنائم اي هذا النبي عليه السلام
جمع الغنائم جمعت بامره فجاءت يعني النار
لتاكلها فلم تطعمها
[Silence]
‏and wasid
wasهى
prop ان فيكم غلولا
الغلول
هو ما يؤخذ ذ
ويغل من الغنيمه اي ما يسرق من الغليمه
وما كان لنبي ان يغل
ومن يغلل ياتي بما غل يوم القيامه يعني من
الغنيمه
[Silence]
غنيمه فليبايعني من كل قبيله رجل
بني اسرائيل
[Silence]
فلزقت يدل بيده
one of the 12 tribes
قال فيكم الغلول
فلتبايعني قبيلتك
‏come and
they would put their together
فلزقت
يد رجلين او ثلاثه بيده
وقال فيكم الغلول
فجاؤوا براس مثل راس بقره من الذهب
it was of gold that was head of a cow
فتنه بني اسرائيل
عليه السلام
الله سبحانه وتعالى
واشربوا
في قلوبهم العجله
فهذا من اشراب فتنه العجل في قلوبهم نسال
الله العافيه فوضعها فجاءت النار فاكلتها
[Silence]
articula
الله سبحانه وتالى
فلم تحل الغنائم رسولنا يقول لنا صلى الله
عليه وسلم فلم تحل الغنائم لاحد قبلنا
ثم احل الله لنا الغنائم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
مي الغنائم
لما راى ضعفنا وعجزنا
صلى الله سبحانه وتعالى
فاحلها لنا madeوصيات
خصائص
صلى الله عليه وسلم
any other
was never
الغنائم الامثال
صلى الله عليه وسلم
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يتقبل منا وان يعفو
عن خطايانا وان
يسلل سخيمه قلوبنا وان يرزقنا الصدق
الصادق والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين